-Guys it is time for
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
Here we go.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond to
that topic.
So, this week I sent out the
#IGotBusted and I asked you guys
to tweet out a story
about a time you got caught
doing something
funny or embarrassing.
Tariq, do you get
ever caught doing something
funny or embarrassing?
-Absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
-Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you all so much
for playing along.
And now I thought I'd
share some of my favorite
#IGotBusted responses
from you guys.
This first one is
from @Brown2606.
She says, "When I was a
teenager, I tried to sneak out
of the house late one night.
On my way out I accidentally
rang the doorbell."
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, someone's here.
It's our daughter."
This one's from @ummjello.
She says,
"My sisters threw a rager
while my parents were away.
We got rid of
all the evidence.
The next day our parents came
home, didn't suspect a thing
until they turned on
the ceiling fan
and beer bottle caps flew off."
[ Laughter ]
"The fan's drinking again."
This one is from @joedeprospero.
Wow. That's a good name.
He says, "I got caught playing
air guitar by myself
and tried to pretend I was
brushing lint off my shirt."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that always happens.
♪♪
Jimmy!
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @bellowssue.
She says, "I was riding with
a friend to her parents' house,
and we were talking about
how hideously some of the houses
were painted
in the neighborhood.
I said,
'Whoa, look at that one.'
She said, 'We're here.'"
[ Laughter ]
"That's not what -- I like it.
It's actually --
What is it,
like a scurvy green?"
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @christie0106.
She says, "When I was 16 I snuck
out to a club in Nashville.
My mom called the club.
They stopped the music
and called my name
across the intercom,
saying my mom was on the phone."
[ Laughter ]
That's good right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one's from
@pastorkeester -- kester.
[ Laughter ]
@Pastorkester76.
This is -- Sorry. There's one E.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
..."I was explaining to
a co-worker
that I'm bad
at remembering names.
'What about Adam Bell,' he asks?
'Do you know
the name Adam Bell?'
I thought about it and said,
'It kind of sounds familiar,
but no.'
He replied, 'I'm Adam Bell.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
Is that your favorite one?
-Yeah, that's pretty good.
That's pretty good.
-Adam Bell is pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know
why it's making me laugh.
Adam Bell.
-Like, for some reason I hear --
-"I'm Adam Bell."
-I hear him saying it in, like,
the Batman voice though.
-[ Deep voice ] I'm Adam Bell.
-Yeah, yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ]
But does he say the other lines
like Batman, too?
[ Deep voice ]
"What about Adam Bell?"
-Yeah, exactly.
-"Do you know
the name Adam Bell?
-[ Deep voice ] I'm Adam Bell.
-I'm Adam Bell.
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah.
-[ High-pitched voice ]
No, I'm Adam Bell.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Deep voice ]
"I'll fight you for it."
-[ Normal voice ] "Will the real
Adam Bell please sta--
In fact, I, the announcer,
am the real Adam Bell."
[ Laughter ]
This one is from
@martinamelcherm.
She says, "I was in a group
interview for a sales position
at the Disney Store
when I burped
a cloud of marijuana smoke.
It was kind of amazing,
but I didn't get the job."
[ Laughter ]
It was kind of amazing?
-Okay.
-"It was kind of amazing,
but I didn't get the job."
[ Laughter ]
You thought that was
going to be like --
-I mean, you know how hard it is
to burp weed smoke?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I don't. I have no idea.
-Give credit
where credit is due.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This last one is from -- I'm not
kidding -- it's @iamjennymcd.
Do you know Jenny McD?
[ Laughter ]
"Sounds familiar,
but, no, I don't know Je--"
I am Jenny McD.
[ Laughter ]
Hi. I'm Adam Bell.
Want to get married?
Jenny McD.
She says,
"On the way to a wedding,
an erratic driver
was ticking me off.
I flipped him off
as he passed us.
Turns out he was the minister."
[ Laughter ]
Pastor Kester.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.